would you know where the second largest
homeless population is where where like
it's it's a combination of but where
I genuinely felt like I lost some brain
cells right now
[Music]
you guys want to see a dead body yeah
yeah let's see it how dead well that's a
rhyme question it's alive first
huh we're gonna watch somebody die
because then
um I mean I've seen pretty shitty stuff
is that this guy is dancing on top of an
18-wheeler oh
is he doing it well
yeah I need you does he does he fall off
of it does he go on a bridge I need
dancers to review his dance skills
before the death I got you because
that's cool with you guys all right we
have a bunch of dancers here let's let's
figure it out
[ __ ] Steve so here we go so there's
this is the guy
Focus your eyes here I can't see there's
the bridge Anthony oh [ __ ]
I can't see
well that that was it oh oh okay I see
him you guys want to cry around this way
yeah crowd around
oh my [ __ ]
oh my [ __ ] of course
why do they do this was this your way of
trying to Guess watch senator Tammy
balls
yes a new legislation
yes or no did you guys vote here we go
oh yeah
well
oh oh oh okay
all right
uh I'm still going
doesn't see the second one oh yeah he
doesn't die yeah he doesn't oh [ __ ] he
did a little ducky he's not in that
video but he fell to his death
afterwards wait are you if we get
serious yeah they don't have the video
tell me that guy fell to his death no
way yeah was it uh like died on impact
or died on a run over
um it says that he he was filming
himself dancing and then he's ducking
under an overpass and then after that
after he stands up continues dancing he
then falls from the truck into oncoming
traffic where he is hit multiple times
multiple blunt force trauma how
how did he get up there in the first I
mean it's not hard to get on to a truck
but like what what was the previous is
there a story like so they don't no they
didn't they didn't do any um toxicology
reports on him yet but there's obviously
people are assuming that this guy was on
some kind of um drug drugs will do that
to you yeah
but how is this dancing what do you
think
I'm pixelated I can't tell what he was
doing how how uh maybe people were
watching his life
oh
that didn't say that's a great question
damn there's single digit numbers
probably I want to hear the music that
he heard I know every time I see people
dancing with no music I'm like what what
song He's So troubled what are you
seeing yeah what song you think it is
Joe yeah usually okay usually
I'm a bit racist okay if it's black
votes it's hip-hop or funk music
depending on the age if they're older
it's funk music if they're younger it's
hip-hop if it's white depending on what
kind of white like it's like one is like
maybe surfer rock or maybe it's
psychedelic Rock You know I don't know
right I mean yeah if it's Asian it's
usually like ding ding ding dance you
know really because that's all we got if
they're old if they're old if they're
old if they're young you preface this
with them a little bit racist I couldn't
go to like I don't know like black pink
or something it had to go to ding ding
ding ding ding that's if they're old
they're usually listening to Chun Lee's
stage there is a song that all people of
all Races dance to and that is the one
done
that brought the world together yeah but
I did do that one
if he was listening to that around a
truck I would have jumped on the truck
for sure
that we probably would have pulled over
what this was in L not in LA right this
is in Houston okay this guy was was it
like a social media thing that's La
Behavior though he was just live
um also the truck uh driver was
questioned by police didn't release
without charges so no he had nothing to
do with it did you know over half of the
homeless population is in California
though half of the homeless population
in America is all in California well
they're smarter because it's better
weather that's true way sicker out here
yeah
should chill out here for sure for sure
it's a nice place to be that's why in
Vegas they stick to the tunnels because
it's like the weather is kind of wild
oh yeah what isn't it also illegal in
Vegas to be like uh coffee that's why
okay um do you know where the second
largest homeless population is where
Blair yeah like it's it's a combination
of butt wear
I know you don't even need to Google it
I believe that I thought it was New York
I genuinely felt like I lost some brain
cells it probably used to be work that's
what I thought I'm not sure though it's
for sure in New York there's also
Seattle right oh that was a question I
thought you knew like you're gonna tell
us that's what I thought actually yeah
no no I wasn't wanting to tell us
Anthony pretentious like I have the
knowledge let me ask you you're one of
those guys do you know who the number
one dancer is in all of the world who me
the leader of course it is New York New
York New York Los Angeles Seattle San
Jose San Francisco San Diego so New York
is bigger than L.A uh the city maybe
yeah it looks like it well now if you
yeah it looks like it yeah so Joe is
absolutely wrong Joe's dead I said
California mother [ __ ] face Joe's right
because if you add up all these
California ones these are all California
no that's yeah more than 77 000 that's
Seattle right there wait so New York
state has more homeless people than
California state those are cities I
think they're doing City comparison City
New York City is more than LA and then
California in total is more than New
York got it okay I told you
I told you he's right no he said Blair
he said where which is the the highest
this is where but where there's a
[ __ ] dude dancing on a truck and then
he [ __ ] Falls and dies like that's
like some dumb ass [ __ ] he's 25 years
old oh you know what you know what's sad
is like there's so many different ways
to feel empathy for this but honestly I
really feel bad for like a potential
innocent driver that could have been
killed me too and what they had to see
before like when the guy died dude I
have a [ __ ] crazy ass story with one
of my homies in my crew
um yeah sorry somebody died
somebody died then he got really like he
had a something clicked in his mind that
happens to a lot of people
um he was he's driving in Philly
the car in front of him hit a lady that
was crossing the freeway oh
she bounced up and slammed into his
windshield for a second oh and as soon
as he saw like the blood and stuff on
his windshield his brain told him that
it wasn't a person
like to save from the trauma like he
automatically was like oh that's funny
the he's like somebody spilled a jar of
jam across the windshield like it like
took over and he stopped at a gas
station and he like oh calmly cleaned it
off and then after it was all like gone
and he got home then it hit him that it
was a person and he hadn't even thought
of it the whole time it's like it's like
a phenomenal thing that happened
somebody dropped a jelly stuff dummy on
my car which well there's a little
eyeball in this Jello yeah it's really
like what happens it's like your brain
your brain will make a different story
to so that you don't freak out it's like
this thing that I guess it it happens
like some sort of self-preservation to
preserve your sanity so that you can get
out of the situation so what does it
mean when the opposite happens when a
normal thing happens and your brain
makes it dead bodies yeah I've heard the
psychosis on that you're reading like
Medal of Honor stories is pretty [ __ ]
wild the same way
because like if you've got a medal of
honor you went through some crazy ass
[ __ ] it's like some guys are like
they're with their unit and then like
they reach next to them and like that
used to be their buddy but now it's like
their Buddy's face is like [ __ ]
puddle of goo or whatever and then they
just don't even they just immediately
instantly like you said don't believe it
and it's just like oh my buddies
everybody's somewhere else and then it's
just like just rally forward right yeah
until they have to process it later
right fight or flight yeah it's probably
why so much training goes into that like
if like if you're just a regular person
and you see something that you're not
ready to see yeah like it's not always
going to be exactly what it is I always
thought it was kind of fascinating where
like these guys in World War II would
blow each other up and then go home and
swing down
like they're doing that right after they
they [ __ ] blow some [ __ ] up dude and
they just saw their buddies dead and
[ __ ] all kinds of [ __ ] and the music
didn't even reflect that like today
you'll hear it and be like yeah [ __ ]
god shot my friend All My Friends Are
Dead yeah right but back then it's like
we're having a gay old time don't you
need to have a gay all time if you just
went through some [ __ ] maybe huh they're
like I need to hear my War representing
all music in all avenues yeah my grandpa
didn't want to watch anything like that
escapism did you guys see that new movie
on Netflix All Quiet on the Western
Front no it's a new movie huh
one of the oldest movies ever made no
the new one that just came out oh
there's a new one there's a remake why
would I say new one of the oldest movies
ever made have you ever seen Steamboat
Willie
who's seeing that [ __ ] let me just have
this it's a 1930s movie they made a new
one that's what I'm saying I made a new
one all right anyways
[ __ ] idiot Western Front film uh and
then they just really capture uh in a
really dope way I guess that dope's the
wrong word
um that feeling where everybody who's
young wants to sign up for this war
because they think that they're doing
like right by the country they're being
proud you know for their families
you know celebrating when they're
getting their uniforms and stuff like
that even though the uniforms are like
re-fucking patched up from guy who just
died in front of it
um and then they go out there and
they're singing and stuff but the second
they actually get to the front lines
everything gets real and then you see
guys like [ __ ] panicking they're like
this is what I signed up for and it gets
like super quiet and weird but um I
could imagine
through that kind of showing that same
type of thing where you're [ __ ] like
swinging dancing you're like yeah [ __ ]
yeah we're going to war we're doing all
stuff but then you get there people are
getting blown up and stuff like that
what a [ __ ] huh
yeah all the people that [ __ ] die or
like have to like compartmentalize that
part in their head yeah you know what I
mean just to carry forward and survive
like that that must be the most tragic
[ __ ] you experience as a human you know
I think I'd freeze dude I um you know
how good World War II propaganda works I
dreamed when I was about
I want to say 10 years old back in 1930.
no like so it worked so well that at 10
years old I wanted to be a Kamikaze
fighter pilot what and do a suicide
mission wow what
were two [ __ ] propaganders you
watched it well so around eight or nine
ish right like I think my brother and
his friends got really into uh model
planes like remember those yeah like
from Cars to tanks and stuff they were
so fun and then um I went to my
brother's friend's house and his whole
room had like this Recreation of World
War II where the planes were like this
and he had them on fishing string like
and there was a battle scene and on the
bottom he had this whole [ __ ] desk
with like just the two armies fighting
and I was like that's the baddest [ __ ]
I've ever seen so I started making those
and then and I started reading about it
and I was obsessed with World War II
[ __ ] and I identified more because with
Japan like I didn't know that there was
a American side with Asians fighting it
I didn't know about 442nd none of that
so in my mind I'm like well I'm Japanese
I should be fighting for the Japanese
side yeah and I learned about the
kamikaze pilot and they were my age they
were like 12 years old to 15 or whatever
so I was like they're probably my age
and we're like the same age and I'm like
oh man that'll be so cool if I could be
like them and I can die and be a God you
know they lost though right did you know
back then because that used to piss me
off when I was a kid if I was on the
losing team I was like God [ __ ] damn
yeah
this is this is how I was like this is
how they indoctrinate kids into these
crazy like extremist groups because like
I was susceptible to that because I
found I saw glory and dying for
something and becoming like deity or
something and I was like man I would I
would beg my mom to buy me that [ __ ]
Kamikaze like Karate Kid thing so I
could wear it around my head and she was
hard and I would like pretend that I'm
flying on a plane and just [ __ ] dying
that's the danger with with using an
incentive that's beyond this existence
because I I believe that after I did
that people were gonna like go like like
glorify me and then like I'm gonna be
able to be like remembered and then I'm
gonna be deity yeah Legacy yeah it's
just like the [ __ ] 40 virgins after
you die I do you know it's like you're
72. it's causing you to be way more
detached about how you affect the world
here because this isn't the ending point
and you die and then there's 40 in-cell
Gamers surrounding you and no Wi-fi yeah
and then they're like you don't want to
be with the 40 versions dude they're
[ __ ] like this one for money yeah
they tell us on your dick because
they've never given ad yeah they want
you like all like [ __ ] yoked out and
[ __ ] like unrealistic [ __ ]
laughs
[Music]